what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
why hello there this is my sexy voice
yes yes it is that oh so sexy voice of
Rob mmm-hmm
Morgan Freeman eat your heart out you
got nothing on me old man
[Music]
titty sprinkles what's going on guys so
we are doing another video on how to
kill superheroes and in this video we're
focusing on the Incredible Hulk
now now having said that I have run a
poll well it'll actually probably be too
late by the time you guys see it but
maybe it'll still be up I'm not sure but
I have a poll on Twitter on how like
which what my next choice should be and
I think it's Shazam or Captain Marvel
depending on where you decide to column
a Thor or dr. Manhattan so feel free to
post down in the comments section which
one you think I should do Thor Shazam or
dr. Manhattan because I'm kind of
curious so if you've been reading Civil
War too you probably know that the
incredible hoaxes alter-ego Bruce Banner
was recently killed by a Hawkeye when he
shot him with an arrow so you know that
happened about four months ago and it
was pretty well publicized and so it
really seems just by that that killing
the Incredible Hulk would be a no
brainer just wait until he's back to
Bruce Banner and then kill him however
for the purpose of this video we're
going to assume that we're not lucky
enough to just stumble upon the
Incredible Hulk while he's in his Bruce
Banner form and get the drop on him
instead we're gonna put ourselves in the
worst case situation and we're going to
assume that he's already transformed
into the Incredible Hulk now the fact
that Banner is so vulnerable does give
us an option on how to take the whole if
there were a way to force the hope to
transform back into banner then the
battle becomes easily winnable but is
that possible well an Incredible Hulk
number 250 under the writing a bill
Mantlo we saw the Silver Surfer use the
power cosmic to SAP the gamma radiation
from Hulk's cells which causes him to
transform back into banners and so we
know that it's possible to transform the
Hulk back into banner if one possesses
something as powerful as the power
cosmic now as it conclusion of the world
war hulk storyline and world war hulk
number five we also see another example
of hulk being forced back into banner
when tony stark uses a system of
satellites that he developed to siphon
the gamma radiation from the hulk and
take him from his world wicker form all
the way back down to his human form and
render
my conscious in the process so we see
from these two examples that it is
possible to neutralize the gamma
radiation in the hook cells and force
them to transform into banner and
ideally that is the method that you
would use if you wanted to kill the Hulk
however let's make this more interesting
and let's assume that we don't have
access to any means to get Hulk back to
his banner form and have to face him in
his Hulk form so the question becomes
what makes the Hulk hard to kill well as
we stated earlier the Hulk is one of the
strongest characters in the Marvel
Universe due to his exposure to gamma
radiation his cells have been altered in
such a way that allows him to become
increasingly stronger that angrier he
gets furthermore it has been established
that there's seemingly no upper limit to
how strong the Hulk can become now just
to give you an idea of how strong the
Hulk is he held up a mountain weighing
150 billion tons in Secret Wars number
four in the Planet Hulk storyline the
hoax able to prevent a planet from
exploding by holding its tectonic plates
together and so strength of this
magnitude presents an obvious problem
when trying to kill the Hulk as it makes
him nearly impossible to defeat in
battle now throughout his 50-plus year
history the Hulk has battled several of
the strongest characters in Marvel
Comics and has emerged victorious and a
vast majority of these contests thanks
not only to his unparalleled strength
but to his elite level durability and
his regenerative healing factor now just
to run through some examples of the
ridiculous durability of the Hulk he's
twice survived a blast from a gamma bomb
in Incredible Hulk number 144 and tales
to astonish number 62 he survived a
nuclear bomb explosion in Incredible
Hulk number 440 and he endured an attack
from the Human Torch hitting him at full
force with super nova level powers and
walked away without a scratch in
Fantastic Four number 534 just to
clarify Johnny Storm blasted him with
energy equivalent to the temperature of
an exploding Sun and it did not damage
the Hulk now there are also several
moments where Hulk's extremely potent
healing factor is put on display and
will run over just a few of those here
so you can get an idea of how
ludicrously fast he's actually able to
heal during an encounter with a villain
called vector Hulk
actually has all of his skin and muscle
tissue melted off his body and is able
to regenerate all of it in a matter of
moments an Incredible Hulk number 390
during the future imperfect event
written by Peter David the hope battle
is an evil future version of himself
known as the maestro now during the
battle maestro manages to break the
hooks neck however not only does the
Hulk not die but he heals completely
within a few days
so while exactly how fast the hole can
heal does vary a bit depending on who's
writing the story what we can say
definitively is that the Hulk is able to
heal from almost any physical injury
incredibly quickly and so yeah it's not
hard to see why killing the Hulk is a
task that seems to be at the very least
extremely difficult and perhaps even
impossible so is it even possible to
kill the whole well to get our answer we
will have to look at the comics to see
if it's ever happened as far as I've
been able to tell there have only been
three instances of the Hulk dying and
Marvel Comics the first of these happens
in Incredible Hulk number 444 and a
tie-in issue to the x-men onslaught saga
written by Peter David and what happens
here is that cable and storm team up to
take on the Hulk with cable hitting the
hook with a telepathic joke while storm
zaps his brain with lightning
now while the intention here was to
reboot the hoax brain to free it from
onslaught control it actually ends up
killing him however storm resuscitates
the Hulk with an electrical pulse to his
heart now the other two times of The
Hulk has died are actually somewhat
controversial as they aren't the
mainline version of The Incredible Hulk
for instance at the conclusion of the
future imperfect storyline the maestro
again the future version of holt is
transported back in time to the moment
when Bruce Banner was originally
transformed into the hold by the
explosion of the gamma bomb and maestro
is actually killed in the blast but
since this is a future alternate version
of Hulk and since the mainline Hulk has
survived gamma bomb explosions on more
than one occasion this does not seem
like a possible way to kill him finally
we have another version of the Hulk
dying during the old man Logan storyline
written by Mark Millar in this storyline
The Hulk has become a supervillain that
rules his own section of the country on
the west coast and how we see the hope
die in this story is that he literally
eats wool rain but Wolverine is able to
heal inside the hawk stomach and
disemboweled him from the inside out so
yeah is extremely gross but it's
actually pretty awesome but once again
this is not in mainline continuity but
this version of the Hulk does seem to be
on a power level similar to the Hulk of
the earth-616 universe so it's not
outside
I had the realm of possibility that this
could be a viable way to kill the Hulk
now in addition to these instances there
are a couple of examples of times the
Hulk has been defeated in battle but not
killed I want to draw your attention to
one of these instances because from it
we can actually see a potential way for
the hole to be killed the event that I'm
referring to happens in Fantastic Four
number 166 where the Hulk battles the
entire Fantastic Four team a particular
interest to us though is Susan storm
because in this issue she uses her power
to create force fields to completely
encapsulate the Hawks head thus cutting
off his airflow now this is instrumental
in allowing the Fantastic Four to defeat
the Hulk and it stands to reason that if
the hope needs to breathe to survive
which this does seem to indicate that
Susan could actually have killed him by
continuing to cut off his air supply and
so with that in mind it's pretty clear
that there are a few scenarios that
would actually result in the Hulk being
killed and probably fewer which would
render the Hawks of death permanent due
to his aggressive healing factor and so
I think your best bet is to find some
way to power him down to his human form
and take him out from there but if you
guys can think of anything that I miss
in these comics or in this video make
sure you post a comment below if you
guys are new here to come this explain
hit the subscribe button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like because
YouTube's algorithm and yeah I'll catch
you all later peace
[Music]